mais là messieurs bonsoir décidément on
n'a pas fini d'être surpris par les
rebondissements de la sphère grégory ce
petit garçon assassiné mystérieusement à
l'automne dernier dans les vosges
on croyait l'anc est reparti sur de
nouvelles pistes et voilà qu'arrive un
deuxième meurtre
jean marie villemin le père du petit hic
vient de tuer d'un coup de fusil son
cousin bernard laroche qui était
toujours inculpé pour le meurtre mais
qui semblait sur le point d'être
innocenté le meurtrier s'est aussitôt
rendu aux gendarmes
emilie raffoul équipe est là on ne sait
pas vraiment pourquoi haut pour qu'il a
fait ça et c'était pas bernard laroche
je peux le livre n'importe qui ces
innocents j'espère que le vrai coupable
se retrouver un jour d'accusation en
dénégation de suspicion en inculpation
tout était déjà largement compliqué dans
cette affaire grégory le meurtre
aujourd'hui de bernard laroche par jean
marie villemin va-t-il paradoxalement
éclaircir les choses mais aujourd'hui la
tension a encore franchi un pas si les
proches de bernard laroche
il ya quelque chose qui se produit c'est
que la justice est tellement bien fait
que jean marie villemin affaire facile
pour fou qui va faire trois ans 80 de
prison ou dans maison de dalian et aux
chats plus comme ça qu'elle sortira
comme avant le cir s'en font pas ils
s'entraînent dans le coin et à s'en
sortir d'un une deux trois quatre
quand jean marie villemin est arrivé
pour ton marie-ange laroche et ouvert la
porte n'avait pas peur je suis prendre
n'étaient pas là quoi qu'il arrive et si
mario invités avec google cache des
choses qu'on sait c'est que maintenant
en vagabond et puis que la la police n'a
pas fait son boulot
ah ça fait trois semaines qu'il était
prévenu qu il avait menacé les menaces
et bernard devaud ma belle soeur avait
téléphoné aux gendarmes gens regardent
nous aurions nous sortirait entier sous
le regard de plus voilà ça c'est la
gendarmerie française le juge lambert
actuellement en vacances doit se poser
bien des questions ce soir et se
retrouve face à un nouveau crime est
toujours sans réponse à celui de grégory